this is a production of Cornell
University thank you very much for the
introduction
professor fun rule and I will give you
brief outline of viticulture in South
Africa today and I'd like to ask if you
have any questions right at the end and
anything is not clear just feel free to
ask and of course have some South
African wine and we can discuss the
wines afterwards so like Justine
mentioned on electrodes that Amash
University in the Department of
viticulture enology and for those of you
that might have forgotten way South
Africa is it's the green highlighted
country on the continent of Africa and
as some people get confused with Africa
and sometimes or South Africa because
they sometimes think that Africa is a
country and not a continent so that's
why I'm just putting it out there so if
you look at the country or the map of
South Africa we have nine provinces it's
similar to the states that you have here
here in the US and every state we have a
nine different provinces or States and
then we have the Western Cape which is
our legislative County your capital or
where Parliament is and then we've got
the executive County which is housing
province happen Pretoria at the rate
area that's also the place or province
where all the embassies are situated in
South Africa so if somebody say anything
or mention stellenbosch this isn't only
the picture that pops up the first
picture up in the left hand corner
that's our main campus and the building
that you can see they is actually the
sorry is this building year is the JH
needling building where our department
is situated this is the famous red
square and underneath this is our
library our main library which is one of
the biggest libraries on the African
continent and then we've got a Student
Centre in the
it's something to eat a coffee and then
go to ATM and our administration
building so this is the buzz or the hub
on campus sanim Bosch's also cinemas has
a lot of mountain ranges vignettes of
course it's in the heart of the Cape
Winelands a little bit more about
Stellenbosch University they expected
the 17th century it was first
established in 1866 and it was renamed
Victoria College in 1887
and in 2018 we celebrated our centenary
celebration and we had lots of
festivities happening on campus but also
for our alumni all around the world the
Faculty of the we have 10 different
faculties and the faculties are spread
on five campuses in the Western Cape
with most of them situated on the main
campus except for the medical and Health
Sciences which is on a under premises of
a very big provincial hospital and the
military sciences which is up on the
west coast where they do of course some
military work and some research since
the location of that in our depart or
that we've got 11 different departments
now Faculty of a gross I insist ranging
from Agricultural Economics agronomy
animal sciences Food Sciences genetics
horticulture social scientists and of
course viticulture and enology the
Department of viticulture enology dates
back since 1925 in our building we also
have the entity from wine biotechnology
and I will explain to you a little bit
later why we had I have an institute for
wine biotechnology recently we also had
established the the a GWAS the Institute
for grape and wine sciences and they
were established to create a link
between research and industry for mostly
technology transfer
and we are unique in South Africa
because we are the only University where
you can study a degree program a BC
degree program in viticulture and
enology so we have students from all
over South Africa but also it's becoming
a popular destination for international
students and specifically post grads as
well so in terms of our training we've
got two degrees one is a BC a Greek in
Grapevine in wine sciences and I want to
for those of you that might venture on
the internet and go and look up on this
we are busy currently recruiting so
there might be differences in some of
the information because we're changing
it at the moment
but it's a the first year is basically
ABC here we're do biology chemistry some
great wine and wine Sciences mathematics
computer literacy and crop production
and the second year is some science
modules some statistics as well and red
barn sciences which I will do with
students our academic year starts in
February and it ends in October with the
first semester inning MIT or in May and
the students then write exams after that
the second semester normally starts in
July and it ends in mid-october the
students write exams until the first
week in December our graduations we've
got two graduations one in December and
one in March just to give you some
context because I know it differs here
in the US our students newly start
making wine in our third year after
getting some viticulture experience in
the field so the gate have the
opportunity to make some wine in the
experimental cellar within our building
and our fourth year our students have a
six month internship so we don't see
them for six months and I have lace gray
hair during that period and they only
come back in July of the fourth year or
the final year so during the six-month
period or the final year
I have to do some practical vertical
viticultural experience both in wine or
table grapes because we also have a very
big table grape industry and on the
knowledge aside the students also have
to work in the cellar so we try to give
them six to eight weeks in the vineyard
to see most of the processes in the
vineyard and then they go to the cellar
working the cellar have a research
project and then we try to get them back
in the wing it to do some pruning our
facilities I mentioned previously that
we've got experimental cellar in our
basement it's where our research wines
are made they also have this is also 32
students make some research wines or
when they start playing around with
grapes and experimenting we've got green
our facilities right in the middle of
our building research laboratories where
my colleagues are doing some of the lab
work both on Heastie and and plant meat
metabolics and we've also got analytical
facility with h PLC's etc about two
kilometers away from the main campus we
have our experimental form on both
fallen and it's 14 pictures of vineyards
but we also share it with the rest of
our faculty as they are also dairy and
we'll pear and other water cultural
crops but we have 14 hectares of
vineyards and we also conduct some
research in these vineyards but we also
use these grapes for commercial
winemaking which is then being labeled
under the Sun Bosch University wine
label and sold to the public so in terms
of our student numbers unfortunately I
don't have the 2019 numbers yet because
the students were in your register make
sweet for the new academic here but
normally we have in the range of 150 to
200 students we kept our
graduates numbers at 50 students per
year only because the industry cannot
accommodate such a lot of students in in
the industry because we also have the
results in agricultural college also
else in bed which also offers a diploma
program in viticulture and enology or
cellar technology so it actually becomes
very very big and popular program and
that's why we kept the numbers but like
I mentioned before we have a lot of
international students currently also
joining the program starting with
undergrad already on the postcard side
if our students completed the BC in
Grapevine and wine sciences they can
continue directly with the MSC we have a
couple of new a students at the moment
wrapping up the master's degrees and
then of course there they've got the
option to continue with a PhD I
mentioned before about the Institute for
wine incitive for wine biotechnology and
if a student completed a BAC degree send
engineering or chemistry a four-year
degree that the option to continue
directly with the MSC and then with a
PhD and if a student did a 3 year BSC
program in biology for instance they
first need to do in honors MSC and a PhD
so basically these students can either
work on the flaunt molecular side or on
the east side even bacteria work for
some of my colleagues at the Institute
for one biotechnology in terms of our
research we try to have an integrated
approach to integrate a lot of research
aspects ranging from micro chromatic
aspects barrier characteristics
molecular profiles the fermentations
metabolic profiling and of course the
sensory aspects because the industry is
starting to ask us to combine research
projects and many times we actually all
doing the same thing but just in
different projects so we decided the law
over the last couple of years the
streamlined some of our work to actually
have a bit of flow of research ideas as
well just to give you an idea this is a
table with all the academics my
colleagues in the department with the
different fields of expertise dr.
schreiber working on group and
physiology brand management in remote
sensing miss you nice oven and she's
actually our table grip expert dr. Buble
T he's an expert on remote sensing you
joined us about two three years ago from
Chile and in my knowledge colleagues
merit and Florian working on malolactic
fermentation alcoholic fermentation and
vessel and Marian working on wine aging
aroma and you might have noticed that
they have a very big problem in the
Western Cape but the because of the
drugs we have fires so we have a very
big problem in smoke tank
similar to what they experienced in
Washington State and in California so
one of my colleagues she's actually
defending a PhD next week on the aspects
of smoke change then professor Milani
Bevier and her research group Phillip
young and John were they work on
molecular and metabolite profiling with
in a vineyard sitting and my other
colleagues dr. reberty s authority as
she uses meter metagenomic has admitted
genomic approach something really
interesting that she's been working on
she looks at East genetics in different
under different cultivation practices
because we have encountered a
specifically with old functioning its
Chenin Blanc 20 it's older than 35 years
they normally have a different
characteristic and a different taste and
we started a project by looking at what
actually influences the mouthfeel
properties of this wines by taking it
back and looking what's happening within
the veneer
then my colleague dr. Lillian Evert
she's on the rapid analytical techniques
the expert then also since sensory
aspects
Astrid Boyka working mostly on the
analytical side and some of you might
remember professor antónio Ferreira who
is an extraordinary professor at the
universe at Salamis University but he is
from Porter University in Portugal just
to give you an idea I mentioned that we
are trying to do integrated projects
this is a project on Savio block in all
in the organ area it's about the team to
40 minutes drive from stellenbosch it's
a cool climate area and they the design
was done by Professor London were
initially and they applied these
treatments within the vineyard to see
what the impact of like quality and
quantity will be on the different on the
great quality and the metabolites and
these are four of the publications that
they got from that one veneer by just
integrating all of the results so that's
just to show you what I mean with
integrating all our research projects so
and and it's been working very well in
this case so back to the South African
wine history the first wine was made in
1649 so if you do the mathematics this
year will be the 360 year of winemaking
in South Africa it will happen on the
2nd of February by young from rific
which were sailors going to India and
they needed some fresh fruits and
vegetables while on the way to Indian
and they stopped in Cape Town to get the
necessary resources and on the shipment
that also had some great fun cuttings
and that's how wine started we were also
confronted with luxury and 1880s
all our vines are grafted in South
Africa and I don't know how has anybody
heard of Pina Tosh before tasted it okay
so Peter Tosh is a project South African
with cultivar it's a cross between Pinot
Noir and cincin war and one of the wines
that we'll be tasting today has some
Pinot Tosh component in it as well
of course that's not the only South
African variety or proudly South African
variety we also have Novell and Reuben a
which was crossed in South Africa and
which we also use but not it's not as
popular as Pina Tosh so in 1973 the
wonderful region system evolved and this
is based on the notion of terroir that
wine should taste like the place where
it comes from so our one if a region
system is divided into geographical
units districts ports as well as single
vineyards and in South Africa we have
five demarcated areas geographical units
for wine production and table grape
production so yeah we've got the Limpopo
Province
yeah they basically have only mostly
table grapes the northern cape it's a
very drawing arid region and they get
all the water from the Orange River so
all the agricultural activity happens
along this river and it's mostly table
grapes and wine grapes here as well the
Western Cape of course this is the heart
of all the wine production the Eastern
Cape is a fairly new region as well as
kwazulu-natal which is starting to
become very popular because of its
slopes and hills that it has in close
proximity to the ocean in the areas of
wine production of course we have the
different areas of wine production and
the vary in climatic illnesses is fall
with the
area will the clinical route area being
I call it the hottest whole region we
mostly have only Portuguese varieties
there so if you want good dessert wines
of course in South Africa we're not
allowed to call it port dessert wines
this is the area where you can get it
from the the Cape south coast is much
cooler area and then I see white wines
but also a lot of like Pinot Noirs your
lightest olive rates that's being
produced there and then the coastal
region is also very popular aye-aye
yielding areas that we get then we have
smaller pockets one of region and there
are plenty of things so I won't go
through all of them but it's just to
give you an idea of all the different
wine regions that we have but just in
terms of grape vineyards per region I
mentioned that the clink aru's the very
dry arid region as well and they have
they have the smallest or the lowest
number of great points and in
Stellenbosch the heart of the wine winds
has the most vinius woven its per region
to give you an idea of the vini the
cultivars Chenin Blanc is the most
planted grape variety white grape
variety in South Africa it is also we
also have more shin and Blanc in South
Africa than in France where it actually
originated from and we actually use it
for a lot of wine stands dry wine up
until sweet wines and also for brandy
production because brandy production is
very popular and important in South
Africa then also we have Cabernet
Sauvignon it's a very important drip
variety in the Stan Marsh region and
it's extremely delicate grapes and and
it does well and the salamis region
because of the soul type deep great
soils
I mentioned old mansion and earlier
and a couple of years ago I and one of
the businessmen in South Africa
dr. Rupert he gave some funding for a
project to actually start looking into
old vines because they make it different
style of wine and one of the viticulture
is rose a career started looking into
way all these vines and what potential
do they actually have and they came up
with this list of old vines and of
course most of the younger generation
winemakers they want to get hold of
these fresh and the cost it cost a lot
of course to produce these grapes so
everybody wants to get hold of these
grapes because it has a different taste
and the wine quality is just exceptional
kept classics and some other half some
other friends of mine informed me that
the u.s. walked it takes about 60% of
South African Chenin Blanc so thank you
guys for drinking South African Chinon
and making it great because it is really
good just to give you an idea of wine
cellars wine cellars the most wine
cellars is based in the stellenbosch
region with is this is the statistics of
2017 and of course there are also
different size and some also purchase
cellars you might be wondering if you
only make wine I mentioned earlier that
we also have brandy production but our
wine production actually increased the
last couple of over the los twelve years
or ten years for any production decrease
distilling products also decrease and
then we also have grape juice
concentrate and grape juice production
and there's something really interesting
or the reason for this which have all
gets you in a bit and if we have to rank
ourselves and looking at the rest of the
world the US has is ranked six in terms
of area and the vines and
poor South Africa we are ranked in 14th
position and in terms of wine production
u.s. is in the fourth position and South
Africa in the eighth position so it's
just interesting to see and of course
pane number one and also on the
marketing side what happens with all
those wines which is of course always
interesting please go ahead and taste
the Chenin Blanc and it's say in Davos
one of the brands from Kay classics it's
made by Bravo rods which is a wine maker
that also has its own label so what you
should be tasting it's some crisp lemon
some citrus notes and that's synonymous
with the young-shin and Blanc in South
Africa so we can get the tasting notes
afterwards then in terms of distilled
product consumption per capita South
Africa only consumes about 2.2 liters
per person and that is because there in
terms of the demographics in South
Africa the majority of the population
loves drinking beer and whiskey rather
but near a beer drinking population and
it's we trying to change it but of
course it's difficult to change a
consumers perception because it's a lot
lots of training but it's something that
from wine marketing perspective there's
lots of room to actually improve in and
to actually try to find new ways of
making it a little bit better then
instance of wine consumption I get again
you guys are drinking a little bit more
wine then South Africans because South
Africa only drinks about seven point six
liters yet again I thought as I
mentioned before South Africans like to
drink beer as well and a new craze is
gin and tonic gin it's it's very very
popular at the moment as well
drink amazing about why the food so in
terms of table grape production we have
a couple of areas of several great
production I mentioned earlier the
Limpopo Province this is actually the
province way they harvest it's the first
harvest is harvested it's normally in
October and for those of you that are
interested this is actually where the
Kruger National Park is as well where
you can get on Safari
and then the Orange River also very big
in table grape production area in the
Western Cape itself we've got a couple
of production areas the elephants River
which means the elephant's River the
Bourke River mountain river as well as
the Hicks River Valley which is the the
region or table grape region which
normally finish or is harvested at the
end so in terms of great production in
terms of four cultivars crimson seedless
is the most planted bred cultivar and
and of course Europe and the UK there's
actually one of my friends working in
the industry Sinica she actually singing
some pictures last week showing that she
just shipped a lot of grapes to the US
which was made for Costco I think the
other countries like Chile etc are much
closer because we still need to
transport it over the Atlantic
that's why you need to come and visit
and make in the weekend everything I can
it must be the the market requirements
and also the importers so if somebody
doesn't like the grapes of course then
we can't export it so just some pictures
of red globe and some sugar once within
the field just checking for signs of
course size is extremely important for
table grapes as it is an aesthetic
product to take you back and give you
some information about what's happening
in the current situation in terms of
viticulture before 1994 South African
wines and other agricultural products
were boycotted because of the apartheid
and there was a increase in exports of
South African wines from 1995 onwards
the producer profit margin started to
become really good there was also the
cultivation of the noble cultivar so if
Cabernets Samuels your Merlot's etc I
remember I was a fourth-year student at
that time and my professor told us
please plant only red grape varieties
because this is where you money will be
label you will make a lot of money and I
need to find that five years later
everybody wanted white wines again so
this is what happened during that period
and of course like I said everybody
started forming red group cultivars o
viticulture practices is mostly VSP
vertical shoot Positioning System and
it's a very labor-intensive practice but
there's also proportion of our vineyards
which are used as way we do not release
or we have go Blake like the fringe it's
a or Bush wines and they are even more
labor-intensive so
we try to move away from having very
labor-intensive practices but in South
Africa we do have the labor and that
comes with a different set of problems
which I will address in slide Niemann
attitude then of course also we started
using bits irrigation systems and in
management there are just in the past
everybody mostly did flood irrigation
but we started to become aware of betta
irrigation system like dripping and
micro drips and sprayers so that is what
everybody is using at the moment between
2006 and 2016 grape and wine prices
prices started to stagnate and that of
course put South African wine producers
under financial pressure we also saw a
decrease in the number of grape produces
because people were more interested in
cultivating more profitable crops and if
you go to wine phones in Stellenbosch
you will see currently you will see a
lot of them have some micro breweries as
well so you can decide with you once a
beer or glass of wine
and some of them might have bakeries
some of them even have kettle but you
can buy some bulldong it's similar to
jerky but it's better than jerky
then shoot me when it's a dried mead
with spices and you can find all sorts
of interesting things are also some
other crops like citrus etc which people
are now forming just to break even or
make a little bit profit and of course
those are some of the strategies that
they're falling following to make
themselves profitable also breeding of
cultivars for higher production
production quality versus quantity
becomes a big question mark and it's
been something that a lot of producers
have been working on changing the
vertical cultural practices to different
trellising systems
I mentioned earlier that we have the
labor in South Africa but a couple of
years ago right in the middle of the
table grape harvest in a Hicks River
Valley
they had strikes and people didn't want
to go to work because they said they
won't pay the minimum wage so that ended
up with fruit that were rotting on the
vineyards not being able to be packed
and shipped to the US and to other
countries and government had to
intervene because of course it's a very
big commodity in that area and also
labor provides labor in the area and of
course mechanization we try to have
increased mechanization but of course
there's always two sides to the story
and have less labor inputs presently
these are some interesting things that
happen the last couple of years the
profitability is full and the pressure
just last week there was a very big
industry day in Cape Town and it became
clear that South Africans wine South
African ones are still very cheap and
people are always amazed when when they
start talking about price point of wine
so bulk wine sells for about four and
fifty a litre so wholesalers and 550
litre overseas so the the strategy was
basically to increase more packaged
products or bottled once instead of bulk
wines how wine stock labels are also
below and that is because of the drought
we experienced it for three years
last year was particularly bad I'm sure
you guys saw on social media and all
over the world how we struggled and but
fortunately some of the freaker's
gave some water to the city of Cape Town
which were able to help the rest of us
and yes we were limited to 50 liters of
what a day so it was quite tough at
times but we managed to pull through and
the past season who had a bit of winter
rain still not at the level that we it
should be but at least they will be
sufficient so moisture to help with the
vines for the growth growing season
being something very topical at the
moment
even your president got involved during
the discussions a couple of months ago
and he told our president it is act
together and sort out this problem it's
a land reform so it's a very sensitive
issue in South Africa at the moment and
I got word from a friend of mine working
in government that they're not going to
change it very drastically at the moment
because of all the emotional aspects
that goes with it because they didn't
want to compensate farmers for doing
this so like I said this is something
that's often happening at the moment so
if you hear anything about land reform
you more or less know what's happening
or have an idea in terms of future
aspects we're looking into more
precision viticulture also we want to
have smaller producers are overpowered
by bigger producers which is of course
not a good thing I'm ancient production
versus quality quality quantity
mechanization should increase and then
of course planting of cultivars which
are drought tolerant we need higher
production and of course climate change
aspects we should keep in mind that as
well this is a face vineyard robot robot
eggs or we call him gussy it's the
prototype it's a collaboration between
the CSR and the Institute for grape and
wine sciences and they were so tasting
the sea last year I didn't speak I
haven't spoken to my colleague yet if
out what's happening and how does is
doing but I know just before I left in
July
does he went for some tire repairs
because he tipped over in the vineyard
while they were looking at some pruning
strategies also the years of am 38 which
is also of course to scan to the soul
and to see to check for the water status
in the subsoil so I want to conclude my
presentation with a video while you guys
are sipping on some finny Tosh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
down near the southern tip of Africa
lies the South African city of Cape Town
it's regarded as one of the world's most
beautiful cities and is a highly
sought-after tourist destination with
world-famous attractions like its
beaches the waterfront and of course
Table Mountain Cape Town is also the
gateway to the renowned Cape Winelands
where over 95% of South Africa's wines
are produced they are among the most
respected wines in the world and there's
quite a story to tell about them or
rather there are two stories to tell the
one is about making better wines the
other is about making wines better
[Music]
[Music]
it's really no surprise that South
African wines are so highly regarded
after all we have over 350 years of rich
winemaking history to draw on it's a
history that includes Dutch German
Italian and French influences embracing
all the best traditions of old world
wines but our wine making industry is
also young enough to explore more modern
new world styles
[Music]
the other factor behind the quality of
our wines is the extraordinary geography
and climate of the region the kate wine
that's full within the cape floral
Kingdom the world's smallest but richest
floral Kingdom
[Music]
there are more plant species in this
southwestern corner of South Africa than
there are in the entire northern
hemisphere this natural wealth is a
result of the region's unique landscape
it has the oldest of viticultural soils
in the world it embraces two oceans the
Atlantic to the west and the Indian to
the east both of which brings sea
breezes mist and fog and it has various
mountain ranges slopes and valleys which
offer micro macro and mezzo climates
with different degrees of sunshine shade
and shelter these influences make for a
spectacularly diverse range of
environments and conditions it presents
endless winemaking opportunities and
offers winemakers an incredible palette
with which to express themselves
[Music]
to match the sights there's also a wide
range of grapes we have a uniquely South
African red variety pinot Tosh which is
a cross between Pinot Noir and Hermitage
and there are more Chenin Blanc
vineyards in South Africa than any other
country add a number of other major
varieties and dozens of recently
introduced grapes along with some very
old vines and you have the makings of
extraordinary wines enjoyed and admired
throughout South Africa and around the
world
if our history and environment have
helped us produce such good wines it's
only right that we should think of our
future and look after our natural
resources for this we take our cue from
the FEM Sun the indigenous people of
South Africa 80 thousand years back they
were the original environmentalists
living in harmony with nature and taking
from the earth only what it could
replenish the South African wine
industry is taking its responsibilities
seriously thanks to the biodiversity in
wine initiative more of our wine land
has been set aside for conservation than
the total area under vineyard and almost
all wine producers farm according to
established guidelines to manage water
resources and ensure sustainable growing
methods of course it's not enough just
to be earth friendly our producers need
to be people friendly to through
organizations like the wine industry
ethical trade association and the
Fairtrade foundation investment in
programs in infrastructure constantly
improves working and living conditions
it's significant that South Africa has
the most Fairtrade wines in the world
these principles have vastly expanded
our definition of quality one since 1973
the wine of origin scheme has certified
the origin vintage and variety of wines
the new integrity and sustainability
seal takes the concept of good wine even
further introduced in 2010 this world
first guarantees the wines environmental
and social responsibility credentials
according to measurable auditable
criteria while also making it possible
to trace the wine all the way back to
the vineyard
[Music]
so by considering the consequences of
how we worked in thinking ahead for the
next generations we're not just making
better wine we're also making wine
better these are some of the reasons
South African wine is up there with the
world's best we're doing good things by
considering our environment and by
embracing the variety in it there's
variety beyond our natural environment -
if you visit us here in the Cape
Winelands you'll see diversity all
around you after all we're not called
the rainbow nation for nothing our wine
routes are set in constantly changing
but always breathtaking landscapes along
them you'll find a plethora of different
people cultures languages and histories
you'll find mountains and oceans
distractions for nature lovers and
luxury lovers thrill seekers and
relaxation seekers you'll find some of
the world's best hotels and guesthouses
sparse golf courses and restaurants and
of course an abundance of vineyards
wineries and estates it's well worth a
visit but if that's not possible
you can always enjoy some of our wines
they're not just good they're better
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
do you have any questions how much does
it cost the student to get a degree of
Asti
you have a hundred and fifteen soon as
well is that as many as you can take
could you take more just like the supply
but they have degrees and how much it
costs it's basically just the reason why
we cap it at fifty students is because
we the industry can't psych at fifty
students every year just from
Stellenbosch I mentioned before we also
have the Agricultural College awesome
bag and we our students actually compete
with him for two defining work so when a
lot of our students do they do
travelling winemaking so after they
completed their degree they will go and
harvest three four maybe in the northern
hemisphere come back to seven is for
three four years and then they find a
place to answer your question it's about
eighty to ninety thousand Rand per year
so I divide that by fourteen almost
fourteen that will be the amount of
dollar and we I think that's why and I
normally ask international students why
do you come and study here and they tell
me they come and study here because it's
a little bit cheaper than the US or even
in Europe but it's still more national
students think for our own students why
can't you call them it's because of the
legislation because it comes from the
region for Porto in Portugal that's why
we not allowed to call it so we have to
call it fortified wine it's just
legislation things matters so the same
with champagne we're not allowed to call
champagne champagne even though it's
it's definitely drought and also great
prices because producers they don't get
a lot of money for the grapes but we've
been told last year and this year it's
going to change and you can see that
this already and a an improvement in
that regard because they're not getting
higher prices for the grapes so but with
a drought of course it grabs become very
scarce so now it becomes a competition
who can't afford the grapes in a concert
lots of people are excluded again but
our difference a drought and the grape
and the under stress drought stress as
well as great prices what do you think
because I'm 20 so that's why I'm yeah in
the States
doing very shrivel to see if that will
improve our quality or what actually
happens in the berry and nobody has done
the work before in South Africa lots of
groups in there in Australia has done it
in Europe as well and of course the
group of Bacchus killer I don't know if
anyone is working on it on this side of
the continent just to see what the
impact would be and I agree some people
say it makes it better and it's not but
it's all about the timing we were
talking I did my final presentation last
week and we were talking what is the the
window what is the time frame in your
period to harvest the Grouse because
some producers or winemakers say you
need to leave the grapes longer to get
that flavor development so it's a big
debate and I will continue I'm actually
continuing the project that I started
here back in South Africa to see if we
can find some something useful from it
so maybe I'll have an answer for in a
couple of months so I work in apples and
Hearthside reproduction and we've seen a
huge increase in the states in terms of
number of producers and overall
production of hard cider anything
similar in happening in South Africa
it's later becoming trendy there as well
as fodder
we call it decider but I've learned that
cider in the US is also apple juice
which was really confusing the first
couple of times I went to the shop but
cider is very popular mostly because of
this big problem that we have in terms
of profitability so people will not
rather produce apples or to make cider
from it than grapes because it's too
expensive etc there's a very big market
for cider because one of the very big
companies in in South Africa is called
this tell and they export a lot of
siders of course in South Africa and
also in the rest of the continent
it's called Savannah it's dry but you
can drink it that's the logo they've got
so they do exception in awhile and
people love the ciders and they also
have a sweeter style of a cider so I
think that's why it's also good I spoke
about the demographics earlier because
that a lot of people like to drink the
dry bone dry cider so that's why they
also produces sweet this file finder so
yes they Sanders definitely also a as
well as beer and whiskey this is also
very popular this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu